this is 103.3
wxojlp northampton and this is the debut
episode of midweek politics i'm david
pakman our phone number here is 413 so i
want to take this time
to welcome in senator john kerry from
the u.s senate senator kerry thanks for
joining us today
i'm delighted to be with you thank you
it's the week of november 5th 2008 and
we have a new president-elect barack
obama winning in what some are calling a
landslide victory yesterday well we're
we have some cameras in the studio we
did a trial run of this and now we've
actually got what i guess is our debut
episode of the tv version and we're glad
to be on uh not only locally on
northampton cable access tv and of
course on youtube and uh you can
actually see these videos or you might
even be seeing them
right now the healthcare bill has as
most of our audience i'm sure has heard
past it's an okay bill you're listening
to the david pakman show
hey welcome to the show i'm david pakman
and that's right it's no longer midweek
politics it's now the david pakman show
so hold on i am getting a thumbs up from
my producer that there has been a
message posted that appears to be from
anonymous on downloads
downloads.westborobaptistchurch.com is
and anonymous are you taking
responsibility for this
yep we just did it right now this very
second all these other sites are down
because
there you go
uh elizabeth warren really great to see
you today and thanks for coming in it's
so nice to see you thank you great thank
you have you heard about the new way to
open bananas lou
yeah you've heard about it pinch the top
instead of the bottom
you get the whole thing that way let's
switch to natan now and give him the
tana shout out right so i've got one of
these uh
crickets i guess yeah is what louis
i don't know what it is
it's not too salty okay it's crunchy
louis
you know what day it is
you're doing it right i'm ready what do
you got there t
yeah i got like two hours of sleep
all right it's a great start to election
day
cheers
president obama wins mitt romney was an
incompetent candidate he never had a
chance ohio just called for president
obama he won i'm featured in the movie
as a gay teen
that the movie is dedicated to who
committed suicide i i'm obviously not a
teen and the pictures from when i was 20
something i'm not gay i wasn't bullied
i'm alive i mean i just don't get what
the hell's going on here cause we've
been speaking with neil degrasse tyson
congratulations on the great book really
enjoyed reading it oh thank you thank
you so here we have this is the dave
debut of
hate mail number two patriot mail
david it's clear to me and probably the
rest of the world name and i want to
bring in david peck when he interviewed
him in 2010 on his radio show and joins
me now and joining us today is rebecca
ann who's a psychic medium and author
you must have some alternative music
taste that i i don't know if i can
understand all the words okay let me
jump in right now let me jump in right
now hold on a second let's all go one at
a time
all of these things are common themes on
the show so so far anybody who listens
to the show would know all this stuff
lewis is in a metal band it's all online
there's videos and he's coming over now
with the durian
and
it is a little bit ranked he has some
plates and he's going to attempt to uh
oh you've already cut it he's bringing
it in
oh my goodness that that is absolutely
rancid
that is really concerning
do you smell that the big news is that
donald trump has won the presidential
campaign and is now the president-elect
of the united states i went to the
mirror that was closest to where i was
at the time and realized that i had a
big red dot on my chin
and i leaned in and got very very close
to the mirror and realized that some of
my beet soup known as borscht that i had
had earlier that day for lunch
apparently had splashed onto my face and
i did the entire show with about a half
inch red dot of dried borscht on my face
dave i guess pat didn't get to memo that
if you use a courage or bring that up
he's going to get hung and beat up and
abused i'm joined today by roger stone
who is a political consultant new york
times best-selling author roger you're
an in-demand guy these days it seems
everybody including people in government
want to talk to you what i do is i pick
up the burger and flip it as i bring it
up to my mouth
right
and the sesame seeds are now on the
bottom
and that's how i bite it and as you can
see the entire tower is teetering and
tottering right now and pat looks so
nervous it's amazing how nervous that
looks
uh oh no
that's it how was it that looks shocked
at what just took place
melania trump
has liked on twitter
our video questioning how she got an
einstein visa and let's talk about this
with don giordano david pakman radio
host in their respective cities
philadelphia and boston as they are
gentlemen nice to see you the [ __ ]
they feel amazing incredible you like
[ __ ] i'm sorry you like let's i don't
know anything have you ever said that
we're [ __ ]
i don't think so would you date a [ __ ]
it's a pejorative it's not a term i use
amazing it is great to welcome back to
the program today andrew yang who is an
author and entrepreneur and notably most
recently running as a democrat for
president in 2020 i genuinely did not
realize that crowder does a comedy show
oh yeah yeah so when he so the show is a
comedy show wow
yeah a lot of it is funny he does some
funny [ __ ] he really does whether you
agree with him or disagree with him he's
done some hilarious bits i genuine i'm
i'm reacting in real time because i had
no idea
um
what move
yeah
i think that's me oh no so i'm gonna go
back on my end actually good game david
very good game the who has now declared
covid19 a global pandemic
uh pacman
pedro from colombia
oh soybean you know
i haven't talked to you in a while so
you know i had a question for you
congratulations on 1 million subscribers
presented to the david pakman show
joseph r biden jr will be the
president-elect of the united states
defeating donald trump i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
baking and only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know uh earning season is over
and it's time for you to show us your
zucchini
that's very
clever protesters have now broken into
the u.s capitol they're inside through
this door i'm told by a side door but i
have seen protesters at this location
they're inside it is a real pleasure to
welcome to the program today noam
chomsky one of the most renowned
intellectuals of our time all these
people including yourself are going to
see miracles unfold here mike are you
saying even
even even a jewish guy like me will see
jesus
okay
thank you thank you thank you for 1
billion views on youtube we really
couldn't have done it without you i mean
without you
i'm sitting here talking to a camera in
an empty room quite depressing but
thanks to you we're at our first billion
here's to the second billion